[Music]
the perfect hero is someone who
genuinely like doesn't really see it
coming
you want somebody who is open to change
maybe a little uncomfortable with it
that is a key is
finding someone who is at that point in
their life
where they're ready you're kind of like
the wizard of oz behind the curtains
like you're making everything happen
[Music]
my name is danielle gervais and i'm the
evp of
casting and talent at itv america i've
come up
in unscripted television and moved over
into
um into casting through a series on abc
called wife swap
real lives real drama on this season
i'll fix my family
an all-new forged in fire was pawn stars
one i saw that on your imdb
we're casting the items and then
certainly doubling back and make sure
we've got good sellers
good luck too with the emmys coming up
as well
[Music]
how does it start from the second that
you find out that
there's going to be a new season what
what is the first
step that happens the first thing we
need to do is determine you know where
are we going
once we identify the city we have
obviously this is a team of people
we'll sit down the initial war room and
we'll say let's talk about
what stories have we already told on the
show
what stories do we want to tell on this
show
we were trying to tell that story of
reverend noah
two seasons prior we just never found
the reverend noah
we never found it so that just happened
our mission this week
is to help noah take the past out of
pastor and find faith in himself
are we looking at like a day where
you're like having lunch brought in and
you're just hashing out literally every
emotion and story that you could access
i don't know if we brought lunch in but
we had candy and snacks i know
i remember that um there's always snacks
we will also in that initial meeting
pull in our partners at scout
who are the creators of the show and
that's where we really hash it out
and we talk about like things like how
political do we want to get
because you also don't want to hammer
people we never want to forget
what was special about that initial
iteration
like a slob who's ready for a make
better right
so you've had your big war room meeting
um you've decided on your location and
some of the key themes that you're going
to be exploring
in that season what happens next the
next thing is i have to figure out
you know who's going to go to the city
what are we going to do when we get
there because we're not out there for
very long we have budgets we'll
immediately contact
the film commission in that city they'll
help us sort of
steer to some degree you'll have two
people hit the ground in the city
with a plan of attack and you'll have
usually a two people team
back in the office with me doing all of
the outreach
you know remotely which is also huge
so they'll meet people love them and go
you gotta interview this guy
so then the team back in the office will
typically take that interview on so that
the team on the ground can continue with
their work we make little
you know cute flyers and we walk around
you gotta be pretty friendly to be in
casting you really you're gonna be able
to talk to anybody
um and certainly there's people that are
completely weirded out
by it we'll see businesses that we want
to hit a dog groomer
and and lo and behold rihanna it comes
out and she's you know six foot three
with this incredible story
i was asking one of my producers i was
like what's your favorite story of
finding someone
we had a gentleman marcos who owned a
fish
shop they went to that fish market every
single day because they just felt like
there was such a vibrant like life to
that place
that it just was prime so they went
every single day for two weeks
and suddenly they peeked back behind
like a um stand and they saw this fedora
what's the obsession with that where did
it come from marcos
in mexico all the time we say hey
compadre
a little stalkerish at some times i'm
not gonna lie
i'd be remiss if i didn't ask if you
were like secretly looking for people
who clearly have incredible hidden bone
structure
it is always fun to say like especially
if you've got like this big bearded guy
who hasn't cut his hair and it's like
what will he look like at the end of all
of this
[Music]
from what you're saying it sounds like
the casting will really flow from
the story themes you want to emphasize
rather than
you find some person who just pops for
some reason
it is absolutely both it's rare that
you're like here's the exact story you
want to tell oh my god and this person
is perfect and it like
comes together kenny um
who was in kansas city you know one of
my favorite
i love all of the episodes of course but
he's one of my favorite heroes
and the producer was at a bar watching a
croatian soccer game
and there he was his dog had passed away
and he was a you know an older gentleman
living alone
and on paper you know there
and then once it came to life he himself
was such a lovable um
rootable hero he's one you know he's one
of my he's one of my favorites
you've developed this list of good
candidates with a combination
of remote interviews and on the ground
reporting
is really what you have to call it what
happens next in the process
we pitch quite a few to netflix they
have such vision
and they support us and you know these
interviews aren't always pretty
right we're doing them via skype these
aren't professional
people in terms of being interviewed and
they're nervous and
so netflix is able to see through a lot
um in that regard but a land on let's
say eight heroes
will probably pitch i mean internally we
will look at
frankly like hundreds um but in terms of
the network you know we'll usually
triple that number to show to netflix
there are some where it's just like we
all just go oh my god
yes and then there are others where we
can be split because it's all very
subjective right
what sort of diligence do you have to do
when you're casting these people to make
sure that
they don't blow up in your face in a few
months when the show comes out and
somebody's killed somebody or done
something terrible
we won't even pitch anyone to netflix
until
we at least have done as much
preliminary diligence as possible so
we'll search lexisnexis and those types
of things
we'll do a pretty deep sweep on social
media back about 10 years
with some people you know that can be a
deal breaker
they are the secret sauce they are
incredible and they
um you know i can't say enough about how
special
bringing the five of them together has
been it's been incredible but the
heroes
each one of those heroes serves as the
foil to that episode right
so they help anthony shine they help
caramel shine like
we have we sort of have a list where
when we when we look at somebody as a
potential hero
we always want to keep those guys in
mind you know what will they help bring
out in our fab five and vice versa
and so it sounds like when you're
casting for this show in particular
it's really about how well that
these people will amplify the story
themes that you're looking to drive home
rather than are they good at sound bites
my
team is incredible they have a gift for
really identifying like who
who's gonna take the journey in a really
authentic
um way and who's in it for the free
couch
right because that's a thing
[Music]
are they authentic i mean at the end of
the day
we can we can teach people how to put
the question back into the answer
but you can't fake emotion
and you can't fake somebody's journey
you